Hello everyone and welcome to the LangFocus channel.
My name is Paul.
This is another quick video about a linguistic concept.
This one is about something called "Diglossia".
This word "Diglossia" originated from a Greek word
meaning a state of being bilingual.
"Diglossia" is a situation in which a community
uses two different languages
or two significantly different varieties
of one language for different situations
The way it typically works is that one dialect or language
is used for a casual every day interaction
and a different standard language is used
for more official, formal purposes.
The dialect or language that is used
for daily communication is typically a "Low Variety",
meaning that it is not formally learned
and the speakers don't formally learn
its grammar or how to write in that language.
It's merely learned as a spoken language.
The language used for more formal situations
is the "High Variety"
It is the language that is learned at school, formally.
And speakers learn how to write in that language and they
learn the formal grammar rules of that language.
In many cases, the community considers this "High Variety"
to be the "pure" or "correct" form of the language
and they want to keep it the same
and not let it change.
The Low Variety, on the other hand, is more flexible
and it's more likely to change over time
because it is not restricted
by the rules of the High language.
"Diglossia" is very common around the world.
The most commonly discussed example
is probably the Arabic language.
In every Arabic country, there are different dialects
that differ in grammar, vocabulary and pronounciation
from other dialects but also from Standard Arabic.
Standard Arabic is a very codified language,
which is basically fixed in its rules
and doesn't really change
while the dialects are constantly evolving.
In casual speech with other locals,
Arabs exclusively use their local dialect.
But in writing, in formal speeches,
and the news broadcasts, Standard Arabic is used.
And Standard Arabic is also used as a "bridge language"
when communicating with speakers from other dialects.
But really only when necessary,
only when there is some problem communicating.
Another example is in Italy, where there are numerous
regional languages that function as the "Low Variety"
while Standard Italian functions as the "High Variety".
These regional languages
are indeed distinct languages.
Even though they are Romance Languages
that are related to Italian, they are different languages.
But they are often refered to as dialects
because they are not formally learned at school.
In recent times, these regional languages
have faded to some degree.
But "Diglosia" is still very common in Italy.
There are lots of people who speaks a regional language
at home  or with their close friends.
But with people who are less familiar
and in formal situations, they speak Standard Italian.
Another example is the German language,
which has one "High Variety", Standard German.
and many different "Low Varieties".
Inside Germany, a lot of the "Low Varieties"
have disappeared or are starting to fade.
But one interesting example is in Switzerland.
In Switzerland, Diglossia is almost entirely a distinction
between spoken communication on the one hand
and writing on the other.
People in Switzerland don't really accept the idea
of their dialects being a "Low Variety".
So they tend to use their dialect in all spoken situations,
even informal situations.
And Standard German is used only
for reading and writing.
For people who grew up with no real distinction
between a "Low Variety" and a "High Variety",
Diglossia might seem like a bizarre situation,
that's difficult to wrap their head around.
But languages and the way we use them
are fascinating and full of mystery.
The concept of Diglossia is one that will definitely
come up in a lot of my future videos.
So I wanted to make a quick little video about it
so that you are familiar with the concept.
Now I want to take a moment to say thank you to all
of the people who have supported me on Patreon so far.
Because that is a tremendous help to me,
it really helps me justify the huge amount of time
that I invest in this channel.
If you find LangFocus and its videos valuable,
the main thing that you can to do
to support the channel
is to make a pledge on Patreon.
Even if it is just  a small amount
of one or two dollars or something,
that adds up and it becomes
a significant help to the channel.
Some other people have asked me
how they can make a one-time donation
rather than making a monthly pledge on Patreon.
And, if you look at my channel page,
you will see a blue "Support" button.
If you click on that button, that's a way to make a one-time
donation to the channel through Youtube directly.
Some of you are unable to support
the channel with money and that's okay.
But there are other ways
that you can support the channel.
You can support the channel
by sharing videos on Facebook,
or twitting my videos when they're released.
That's a big help as well.
And there might a few of you who want
to do something more significant to help out.
If that's you, than one possibility is for you
to help out with the GEOFocus channel.
If you would like to volunteer some
of your time to do some research,
or writing for some of my videos on the GEOFocus
channel, then that's a possibility as well.
And if you're an experienced editor and you would like
to do some editing work on some of the GEOFocus videos,
then we can be in contact and discuss that as well.
It's hard to do that with the LangFocus channel
because the videos are so complex
and I like to be in complete control of them.
But, for GEOFocus, it's a little bit easier.
So if you would like to support LangFocus
and GeoFocus in any of those ways,
then it would great and I would be very grateful.
But, in the meantime, I appreciate your viewership.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day!